5490 postes supprimés en Europe Alcatel
Lucent vient de donner plus de précision
quant à la mise en place d'un vaste plan
de restructuration annoncé en juillet
dernier la France et le pays le plus
touché avec 1430 postes supprimés entre
des parts volontaires et licenciement
dans le cadre de ce programme
performance l'équipe entier de
téléphonie prévoit aussi d'abandonner
les zones géographiques non rentables
dont le campus de Vélizy c'est ce qu'on
a pris les quelques 2400 salariés de ce
site vendredi dernier c'est quand même
un gros choc parce que
le nombre de suppressions d'emploi
annoncé est quand même bien bien plus
important que ce qu'on craignait
là on est quand même 1430 sur la France
c'est c'est énorme
et qu'en plus la fermeture de du site de
Vélizy c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le
choc ici il faudra desmobilisation il
faudra sûrement qu'on aille au siège
social et puis il faudrait aussi qu'on
au moins sur la zone de Vélizy qu'on
puisse organiser des mobilisations
avec avec les salariés des des
entreprises de la zone qui sont
concernées aussi je pense à Thalès je
pense à PSA qui sont aussi dans dans le
même genre de problème et il faut
vraiment qu'il y a une réaction de de
tous les travailleurs de de la zone quoi
une partie du personnel environ 500
personnes devraient être reclassées sur
le site de villarso à Nozay dans
l'Essonne avant 2014 le gouvernement a
fait savoir qu'un plan d'action pour
l'ensemble de la filière des
équipementsiers de télécom étant
préparation il prévoit une relance des
investissements des opérateurs dans les
réseaux à très haut débit depuis
plusieurs mois nous sommes confrontés à
un certain nombre de plans sociaux
c'est une c'est souvent des conditions
évidemment dramatiques pour les pour
pour les salariés moi je serai à la
disposition évidemment si le souhaitent
les salariés de Vélizy pour pour
intervenir pour les aider pour
contribuer à ce que à ce que des choses
puissent être faites nous venons
d'apprendre cette cette nouvelle donc je
peux pas aller plus loin si vous voulez
techniquement là là aussi sur sur des
choses qui pourraient être envisagées de
son côté Valérie Pécresse député UMP de
la deuxième circonscription où se situe
Vélizy a fait savoir dans un communiqué
qu'elle avait demandé au gouvernement
d'agir au plus vite pour le maintien des
emplois